hi everyone today we're going to talk
about compress sensing and dynamic mode
decomposition which is a recent paper
written by myself
Josh Proctor Jonathan - and Nathan cuts
in the journal of computational dynamics
so a little bit about what dynamic mode
decomposition is first so DMD or dynamic
mode decomposition is a data processing
method originally developed in the fluid
dynamics community which takes large
datasets typically a velocity fields or
vorticity fields in time of a fluid
simulation or a fluid experiment and
what the dynamic mode decomposition does
is it provides a spatial temporal
decomposition of this data into modes or
dynamic modes that are spatially
coherent and oscillate and/or decay or
grow at a fixed frequency in time okay
so the d md method is essentially a
data-driven method this works equally
well with data from experiments or
simulations or historical records as
long as our data is time resolved so we
have snapshots of data in time this is
either velocity field or vorticity
fields we take these snapshots and we
reshape them into tall vectors so my
vectors X naught at time T naught X 1 at
time T 1 all the way up to X at time T M
minus 1 so I create this data matrix of
snapshots and then I create a shifted a
time shifted matrix X prime which has
all of these snapshots of data at one
time in the future ok so now instead of
X 0 to X n minus 1 I have X 1 to X n now
in the process where we take these
snapshots and turn them into vectors X
we can easily get millions or billions
of degrees of freedom or a million or
billion tall vector in many high
dimensional fluids applications as
essentially this would with this would
this would correspond to the number
of degrees of freedom of my system okay
so in this image on the right
courtesy of love is in there there
particle image velocimetry system can
generate tremendous amounts of velocity
field data which we would then stack
into this matrix X and the time-shifted
matrix X Prime at the next delta T in
the future and dynamic mode
decomposition is built on this
observation that the data at a future
time X prime may be related to the data
at a previous time step X by some large
linear operator a now this is not saying
that our dynamics our fluid dynamics are
linear because we know that maybe your
Stokes are inherently nonlinear in in
many situations but we're going to
relate the data in X to the data at a
future time step in X prime by this
large linear operator a and this
operator a has enough degrees of freedom
to approximate the evolution of the
system even though it's it's nonlinear
so dynamic mode decomposition is
interested in finding the leading
eigenvalues and eigenvectors of this big
a matrix the best fit linear operator
that tells me how data in X maps to data
at a future time step in X prime okay
now if these were reasonably sized
matrices we could do this using the
pseudo inverse we could get a equals x
at a future X prime times X dagger where
X dagger is the pseudo inverse of X
right we just pseudo inverse X and solve
for ade but if this is really a fluid
system or some high dimensional system
maybe it's a climate or a neuroscience
system where I have millions of degrees
of freedom in X then this a matrix would
be million by million and it would be
too large to even represent let alone do
an eigen decomposition to find dominant
eigen values and eigen vectors so
dynamic mode decomposition essentially
amounts to an algorithm to find these
leading eigen values and eigen vectors
of the best fit linear operator a given
that we don't actually ever want to
compute this object a so the process is
as follows the first thing I do is I
compute a singular value decomposition
of my data matrix X this is a big SVD
and what I get out are these matrices
you Sigma and V complex conjugate
transpose where the matrix U has columns
which are my proper orthogonal
decomposition modes my p OD modes okay
so for those of you who are used to
doing dimensionality reduction in fluid
systems you'll be familiar with the SVD
of X giving me p OD modes in this matrix
u and these are ordered in terms of
importance from the most energy
containing columns first all the way to
the least energy containing or kind of
the modes that I can neglect to the
right columns of U ok so now instead of
ever computing a this large pseudo at
this large least squares best fit
operator a what I'm going to do is I'm
going to compute a projected on to my p
OD modes in u so what I'm going to do
here is I'm going to take my a matrix
I've never actually computing it but if
it if I had this a matrix I could left
multiply it by you complex conjugate
transpose and write multiply it by U and
what I would get is this expression here
this small expression for a tilde which
essentially tells me what is the low
dimensional structure in this big matrix
a ok so if I keep let's say that the
dimension of my state is n maybe a
million so a is n by n million by
million let's say that my low
dimensional structures my p OD modes i
only need ten or twenty then this a
tilde object would only be a ten by ten
or twenty by twenty matrix okay so
that's the real magic here is that we
take Big Data X we take its SVD we
project on to a kind of low dimensional
operator a tilde which tells me how P
oedema modes are evolving so now I'm
looking at how the p OD coefficients of
each of these time snapshots is evolving
from X to X Prime and it's easy to do an
eigen decomposition of this little a
tilde operator that's ten by ten or
twenty by twenty operator so I take an
eigen decomposition of this little a
tilde operator
and then the real kind of heart of
dynamic mode decomposition is in this
reconstruction in step four where I can
get the full high dimensional
eigenvectors of my big a matrix by
essentially taking linear combinations
of columns of X prime obtained from this
eigen decomposition a little a tilde
okay so the general procedure I collect
my data I organize it into snapshots
that are staggered in time I take a big
SVD of X then what I do is I take this
this very large a operator and I project
it onto the p OD modes of X I take an
eigen decomposition of this reduced
order operator a tilde which tells me
how p OD modes are evolving in time and
then I can use that little eigen
decomposition to reconstruct large high
dimensional eigenvectors of this a
matrix which we're calling phi and step
four okay so our eigenvalues are given
by lambda they're just the eigenvalues
of this little eigen decomposition of a
tilde those are DMD eigenvalues and they
tell me if my mode in Phi is oscillating
that would be a complex conjugate pair
of eigen values or maybe this mode is
growing exponentially or decaying
exponentially and with these modes and
eigen values we can essentially get a
linear model which describes how this
this nonlinear system evolves using
these fees and lambdas and there's some
deep connections to nonlinear dynamical
systems through the Koopman operator
theory and there's a number of
references below that essentially
establish and elaborate on this
connection so to see the dynamic mode
decomposition in action let's consider
data from a simulation of vortex
shedding past a circular cylinder at
Reynolds number 100
so the first step remember is to collect
data so we collect snapshots of the
system in time I basically just take
this movie and I take the first image
the second image third and so on and so
forth and I take and organize those into
large data matrices so in this case I'm
plotting vorticity and
basically take one frame of the movie
and I stack all of those points of
vorticity into a tall vector X naught
the second frame X 1 X 2 and so on and
so forth so I build these two matrices X
and X Prime and now what I'm trying to
do is I apply this dynamic mode
decomposition procedure so I get
approximate eigenvectors and eigenvalues
of this big a operator using dynamic
mode decomposition which is essentially
a regression a linear regression of the
dynamics and what I get out in stage
three is the dynamic mode decomposition
I get modes and I get the time component
of how those modes change in time do
they grow or decay or oscillate or are
they constant and so with those DMD
modes and eigen values I can get a
future state prediction I could possibly
use this for control so lots of
interesting things we'd like to use
dynamic mode decomposition for but as
you can tell from just this brief
overview of the theory there's a lot of
data acquisition required right I have
to collect this large amount of data to
fill X and X Prime I'm doing linear
algebra on this big matrix X and X prime
and so this might be expensive to
collect all of the data and to process
all of the data so what I'm going to
tell you here and this is this paper
about compressed sensing dynamic mode
decomposition is how we can leverage
sparsity and compress sensing ideas to
speed up the data acquisition and the
processing of dynamic mode decomposition
so the goal is to reconstruct our our
full DMD modes but from heavily
subsampled measurements so in many
applications such as particle image
velocimetry and fluids I am limited the
amount of data I can collect is limited
by the the spatial resolution of the
data I want to collect and how
temporally result I want my data to be
in some cases I can't just I can't even
transfer data fast enough from the
camera to the memory for the the spatial
and temporal resolutions I'd like so
what we'd like to do instead is heavily
down sample these images in space so
that we need less we need less data
acquisition and maybe
we can speed up or increase the
bandwidth of our PIV so there's lots of
other work related to sparsity and
dynamic mode decomposition so jovanovich
at all looked at how to select only a
few modes that are most important from
the DMD Jonathan to at all looked at
sparse sampling in time so if I don't
have nice time resolved data could I
infer what the time resolve DMD would be
using compressed sensing ideas
there's our paper which is really
talking about sparse sampling in space
so only taking a limited subset of these
pixels and seeing if we can infer the
full dynamic mode decomposition and then
there is also sparse sampling ideas in
in reference for below so these are all
great uses of sparsity to enhance
dynamic mode decomposition so just a
brief overview of what we're going to be
leveraging here this theory of
compressed sensing the basic idea here
is that there are many high dimensional
signals in the real world so for example
that big X vector of my fluid velocity
field for example or an image that you
take you know a big megapixel image
these might be very very high
dimensional signals or vectors but it
turns out that if you write these
vectors in an appropriate transformed
basis they turn out to be very very
sparse so this is the entire idea behind
image compression or if I take that
megapixel image I can Fourier transform
the image and in the Fourier domain most
of the Fourier coefficients of that
image are small and can be zeroed out
and neglected so this is the basis of
compression of images audio movies lots
of signals are sparse and a transform
basis and so as long as you can map them
into this basis or they're sparse you
can massively compress the amount of
data you need to keep track of so
compress sensing is a new idea within
the last 10 years which says instead of
collecting all of this big data and
then compressing and in some sense the
proper orthogonal decomposition and the
dynamic mode decomposition is a
compressed representation of our full
full fluid field so instead of of
collecting all of this data and then
compressing what compressed sensing says
is in some circumstances it's possible
to collect many fewer initial
measurements and infer what those sparse
Fourier coefficients or sparse transform
basis coefficients had to be to be
consistent with those measurements so
here's a picture pulled from biruni ax
2007 paper this is a great illustration
where what we have is this sy matrix
here is my basis where my signal is
sparse so in this case a is a vector of
Fourier coefficients here sighs like an
inverse Fourier transform so if I
multiplied sy times a I would get a
vector X X would just be my megapixel
image or my fluid velocity field a is
the sparse vector of Fourier
coefficients okay if I measure many
fewer measurements Y right so this is
many fewer measurements than the
dimension of X then in some
circumstances I can infer what the
sparse vector of coefficients had to be
to be consistent with these measurements
and then I could go back and solve for
what x had to be my full image or my
full velocity field so there's there's
no magic here I mean we could have done
this for a long time except that before
compress sensing this would have been a
combinatorial brute-force search to find
the sparse vector of Fourier
coefficients that were consistent with
my nice small measurement my one or two
percent of measurement and so what's
really special about compressed sensing
is that there are theoretical guarantees
on when we can apply convex optimization
routines like l1 minimization where we
with high probability find the sparse
vector a without a combinatorial
brute-force search and what's really
special about this this means that if I
have bigger data then I can essentially
allow Moore's law to catch up and in a
few years my compute
we'll be fast enough to handle bigger
and bigger data which is not true of the
brute force search that we would have
had to do before compress sensing so the
takeaway message here is that signals
almost all signals fluid velocity fields
audio signals images they're sparse in
an appropriate transform basis in this
case for a basis if my signal is sparse
in a Fourier basis then I can get away
with taking many fewer measurements as
long as my measurements are smart in
some way or you know not really well
aligned or or in the same direction as
this the columns of the sparse affiant
basis so as long as I have enough good
measurements of my system I can infer
with high probability what the sparse
vector of coefficients had to be so what
this means is that if I have a fluid
velocity field I can instead of
measuring all million or billion
you know velocities at every spatial
point what I can do is I can measure one
percent of those velocities random at
random points and then I can infer what
the sparse vector of Fourier
coefficients of that velocity field had
to be and then fill in all of the gaps
for the other 99% at the velocity field
very cool theory of compressed sensing
and we're going to use it to make the
the dynamic mode decomposition possible
even if I had massively under sampled
data so the idea of this sparse or
compressed dynamic mode decomposition is
pretty simple okay so I'm just
reiterating the math I showed before
what the DM d is we have DMV modes and
eigen values it's built on this singular
value decomposition of a data matrix X
and it's depicted schematically on the
right here as I take data X and X Prime
I do some math and I get eigen values
lambda and modes feet so what we're
going to do okay and here's just some
examples of what the DMD looks like on
this cylinder data okay turns out it
looks a lot like the PIO D but the that
really doesn't matter for this so what
we're going to do with compressed
sensing DMD is the following we're going
to assume that instead of having access
to X
and ex-prime this big data that's full
resolution we're only going to take
random random pixel measurements of this
this fluid velocity field so in the
cylinder case we're basically going to
act like we only have 1 or 2% of all of
these spatial measurements randomly
we're going to do a DM D on this
compressed data Y and Y prime so the
exact same math I get lambda Y and fie Y
and then what I'm going to do is I'm
going to do this compress sensing l1
minimization step and I'm going to take
my compressed DMV modes v Y on this 1%
data and I'm going to reconstruct what
my full high-dimensional in this case
hundred thousand dimensional DMV modes
would be and so for this case with a
thousand measurements and roughly a
hundred thousand dimensional full state
we see that we actually do a pretty good
job of reconstructing at least the
leading DMD modes now higher higher
frequency DMD modes are a little bit
noisier so it's not perfect but we're
getting away with only measuring about
1% of the data here and we're getting a
pretty good pretty good approximation it
turns out the eigen values are almost
perfect they're nearly within machine
precision which is great so the DMV
eigenvalues lambda X almost exactly
equal lambda Y and the modes are pretty
close using compressed sensing so if we
were limited by hardware if we really if
we could increase bandwidth by
decreasing spatial resolution we might
be willing to do this expensive l1
minimization step because we could get
access to faster flow fields than we
previously could with existing hardware
but this l1 minimization is pretty
expensive so we have an alternative
approach which we just call compressed
DMD and the idea here is if we had
access to our full data let's say we
actually did have all of these high
dimensional measurements X and X prime
instead of just computing DMD directly
on X and X prime which involves a really
expensive SVD we're going to first
compress this data down to a very low
dimensional compressed subspace y and Y
Prime we're going to still do DMD on Y
and Y prime but now instead of doing l1
minimization or this expensive compress
sensing step to go back to our full
dimensional DMD modes VX it turns out if
you actually have access to the full
dimensional data you can just apply this
simple formula you take linear
combination of columns of X Prime and
you get a very very good approximation
to our DMD modes in the full dimensional
space kind of surprising and here is a
comparison with just two modes and
notice this is that high frequency mode
that was hard to get earlier if I take
as few as 21 measurements P equals 21 i
perfectly reconstruct my first mode and
if I go up to 40 measurements this is
just 40 pixels that I'm measuring in the
wake of my cylinder I can get away with
with really reconstructing all of these
DMD modes so just a reiteration if I had
access to my full data but I didn't want
to do this very expensive singular value
decomposition I could just randomly pull
forty or fifty or a hundred of those
data points spatially do DMD on a much
much smaller data matrix Y and then I
could reconstruct and infer what my high
dimensional DMD modes were by taking
linear combinations of my full data X
prime using these transformations on my
compressed data it's really beautiful
very very fast you get a huge speed-up
so you can essentially take cluster size
operations of dynamic mode decomposition
and do them on your laptop now because
you can you can get away with this
compressed sensing this compressed EMD
step and schematically I just want to
you know there's been a little confusion
it's it's a little confusing because we
could do compressed sensing where we
really didn't have access to the full
state data or we could just do this
compressed EMD where we do have full
state data and we're just trying to
speed it up so I want to just walk
through this data flow we have some
source of data if we are in the regime
where we only have access to spatially
sub sampled data maybe we're trying to
boost our bandwidth or we have
unreliable sparse sensors in the
Oshin or something like that if I if I
only have access to sparse sampling of
my data than this I don't have full
state data I have to do DMD on
compressed data and I have to
reconstruct modes by this compressed
sensing l1 minimization we call this
compressive sampling DMD or compress
sensing DMD if I did have access to my
full data so I had all of the data
spatially resolved temporarily resolved
I might still want to make that
computation faster so then I would do
this compress DMD I would take my full
data I would compress it I would do DMD
on the compressed data and then I could
reconstruct modes just using linear
algebra and so this this step on the
right compressed DMD is much faster the
compressive sampling DMD if we had
access to full state data but even if we
didn't even if we only had access to sub
sample data we could still infer what
the full state DMD modes are which is
pretty cool all right so if you had
buoys in the ocean if you had enough of
them you could probably infer the
dynamic mode decomposition of what it
would look like if you had a really high
resolution sensor net and we can also do
an error analysis of these two different
methods so here on the top we have the
compressed sensing DMD where essentially
we only have access to like one percent
of the one percent of the data here this
is a double gyre flow where we have two
basins that are kind of oscillating back
and forth and swirling and if I look at
the l2 norm of the the true DMD mode fee
versus the reconstructed DMD mode fee we
see that our error does go down as we
have more and more measurements so
around 1,000 measurements or about 1%
we're getting pretty low mode errors and
compressed DMD so this is when I have
full state information and I'm just
doing compression DMD and then
reconstruction the l2 norm
drops off much much more rapidly this is
on a log scale and with as few as a
hundred measurements I actually have
very very good agreement between the
true DMD modes
and my compressed DMV notes so two
different options if I only have access
to limited sparse data I can do
compressed sensing DMD it's expensive
though to compute and the error drops
off somewhat slowly if I have access to
full high-resolution data I can compress
it do you compress DMD and I actually
get away with very accurate results and
very very fast computations okay so one
of the last things I want to show you is
just I want to give you an idea of why
this works so there's some beautiful
theory about essentially why compressed
DMD works and the idea is there's a few
pieces so the first fact that's really
important is dynamic mode decomposition
is invariant to write unitary
transformations what do I mean by this
if I take my data X and X Prime and I
shuffle all of the columns of X and I do
the exact same shuffling of all of the
columns of X Prime I get exactly the
same dynamic mode decomposition I get
the same eigen value lambda and the same
modes fee it's very cool property so you
should try this right do your dynamic
mode decomposition but do it by first
swapping all of the columns of X and the
same swapping of all the columns of X
prime you'll get exactly the same DMD so
it's essentially this is because SVD the
singular value decomposition is
invariant to write unitary
transformations so that's one fact the
second fact is the dynamic mode
decomposition is mostly invariant to
left unitary transformations so if my my
compression matrix C was actually a
unitary matrix so for example if I swap
all the rows of X and X Prime or if I do
some other unitary transformation on the
left when I get out my dynamic modes
from my my transform data why they're
exactly equal to my dynamic modes X but
pass through that left unitary
transformation so this is what I mean by
it's almost invariant to unitary
transformations I get the same modes
except their rows are also swapped in
the same order okay so the result is
that the dynamic mode of done
of X and X prime is related to the
dynamic mode decomposition of any
unitary transformation of my data so
what are some some unitary
transformations well the discrete
Fourier transform is a very useful
unitary transformation the PIO D modes
from a singular value decomposition also
a unitary transform so right off the bat
we have a few different transforms of
our our data where we should get exactly
the same DMD modes ok so if I if I do
DMD on my data or I do da DMD on the FFT
the spacial FFT of my data it the DMD
modes I get out are the same they're
related by a spatial FFT now these are
just facts of dynamic mode decomposition
and singular value decomposition and
linear algebra so if but remember our
compression C is not a unitary matrix a
unitary transformation is like an N by n
matrix in our case we're doing heavy
heavy compression so C is not unitary
this is where the theory of compress
sensing comes in remember our data our
data was assumed to be sparse in some
transform basis because basically all
data is so if my data and that's written
on the right here as y equals C times sy
times s so what we're saying is that our
data X is sparse in some transform basis
I then compress sensing essentially
gives you conditions when my measurement
matrix C my compression matrix times
that sparse affine basis I act like a
unitary matrix or an isometry on sparse
vectors s so essentially what's
happening here is we're able to do this
massive compression of the DMD data in X
because that data is sparse and so our
measurement matrix C times the sparse
affine transformation sy act like an
isometry or a unitary operator on that
sparse data that's sparse data so DMD is
invariant to left unitary
transformations and if I had a sparse
data matrix s
then DMD would be invariant to these
near isometry transformations given by
compressed sensing so that's just kind
of a high-level overview of why
compressed DMD works that essentially
relies on the sparsity of my data in a
transform basis and the fact that if I
have enough incoherent measurements in C
then the product of C times psi gives me
something that acts like a unitary
transformation on sparse vectors okay so
the last parting thought here is that we
have provided all of our code online so
you can follow this link download CSD MD
zip we essentially have this nice
example of a sparse dynamical system
that evolves on a torus so here we have
these five spatial Fourier coefficients
that are driven by a sparse dynamical
system they give rise to this nice kind
of these spatial temporal coherent modes
in this plot here and this is really
easy to generate and analyze this data
so you can download the MATLAB codes
that generate this and then you can try
out the different compressed or
compressed sensing dynamic move D
compositions you can try different
compression ratios different kinds of
pixel sampling anything you want the the
MATLAB code is here okay so that's an
overview of our recent paper on
compressed sensing and dynamic mode
decomposition I hope you enjoy and if
you have any questions or comments
please don't hesitate to to email us or
contact us thank you